the us's longest war is over the
pentagon says the last american troops
have been flown out of afghanistan after
a 20-year mission the departure follows
two weeks of chaotic and desperate
scenes in and around kabul airport as
thousands of foreign nationals and
afghan citizens tried to flee
the taliban have now proclaimed
afghanistan's full independence
this time the gunfire heard of a kabul
was different
with the american troops gone people
began celebrating their departure
the u.s military worked all day monday
for the final withdrawal it was one
minute before midnight that the last
plane took off on august 31 america's
longest war drew to a close a new
chapter of america's engagement with
afghanistan has begun
it's one in which we will lead with our
diplomacy
the military mission is over
a new diplomatic mission has begun
because of security concerns secretary
of state lincoln said the u.s embassy in
kabul will stay vacant and its diplomats
will work from qatar
it was also security concerns and a
successful attack on kabul airport why
the u.s government rushed to meet the
deadline at a cost
look there's a lot of heartbreak
associated with this departure we did
not get everybody out that we wanted to
get out but i think if we stayed another
10 days louie we wouldn't have gotten
everybody out that we wanted to get out
and there still would have been people
who would have been disappointed
to those who were left behind secretary
blinken made a promise
more than half the world's countries
have joined us in insisting that the
taliban let people travel outside
afghanistan freely
as of today
more than 100 countries have said that
they expect the taliban to honor travel
authorizations by our countries
we will hold the taliban to their
commitment on freedom of movement for
foreign nationals visa holders at risk
afghans
the taliban said on twitter after the
americans left afghanistan gained full
independence
let's cross to kabul now where
journalist france marty is standing by
france after 20 years the last american
soldier has now left afghanistan is
there a sense of change in kabul this
morning
not that much yesterday night there was
like celebratory gunfire as i've never
heard it before but this was of course
of the taliban forces um in the
city um other people were like uh rather
very or someone told me that his
children were like afraid of the
celebratory gunfire i was just in the
city center it looks more or less normal
not that many people on the street but
shops are open
um there is there was no sense of like
uh
um
as jubilant sense uh people were like
normally going about their work some
told me that they are worried
because like business is bad
no one buys anything no one sells
anything um refugees are still camping
out in the park
so there wasn't that there wasn't like a
scene of celebration today in the
morning in the city center
there had been desperate scenes of
course at kabul airport are the taliban
now in control there is the airport
still operational
and polymon have entered the airport
like and posted like many uh videos on
social media
of of their forces inside the airport
some taliban also made brief statements
in the airport um one taliban official
told uh local channel tolo news that
they have prepared for this that they
will be able to run the airport however
at the moment this can't be assessed uh
completely
plus the taliban themselves can't like
run
air control and everything that is
needed to operate an airport uh but
there are uh their reports uh that they
will get support from qatar and turkey
um to to again make the airport
operational when this will be the case
remains to be seen
what about foreign nationals friends who
still want to leave the country will
they be able to get out are they in
danger
the taliban have
several times assured that people with
the right travel documents are allowed
to depart the country
of course now you have the problem there
are like no international flights from
carnival airport or any other airport um
land border crossings are like only
partly open
for foreign national passport holders
should be possible to like get over land
border crossings um but this is like so
far everyone tried to get on evacuation
flights from kabul airport and now it
remains to be seen how difficult or easy
the taliban will make it for people to
leave
this is a momentous occasion for the
taliban they have declared now that
afghanistan is independent
uh what can we expect from the taliban
in the coming days
it is really hard to say the taliban
have uh not only since they took over
kabul already before they've already
always been vague about what they
exactly want to do they always repeat
that they want a islamic system meaning
that the constitution of the former or
like current islamic republic of
afghanistan
was not islamic enough so they certainly
want to change a lot but how exactly
they will go about it how they will do
this is still unclear
several reports suggested that they
might deliberately have wanted to make
clear announcement until the last
american forces left so it can be
expected that within the next days or
maybe even today
they will announce something and give
more clarity but so far
they have really not said much what they
want to do
france thank you very much that was
journalist franz marty in kabul